Markov processes
can be very general.
They can run in continuous
or discrete time,
can have a discrete or a
continuous state space.
In this class, we'll
restrict ourselves
to discrete time discrete
state Markov chains.
These are the
simplest cases and are
the best to build our intuition.
So the state space is discrete,
here, finite with m states,
and time is discrete.
That is, at any
discrete point in time,
the process is in
one of these m states
and let's say here,
at any given time s.
And again, time is
discrete, so think
about the following process.
You have someone hitting
a drum, indicating
that a transition occurs.
And what it means is that
the chain that was here
will then jump.
Let's say to another
state j at the next time.
So when the Markov chain
jumps it can jump on itself
or jump to another
state like here or here.
And then at time s plus
1 someone hit the drum
and you jump again,
and so on and so forth.
You can think of a very active
frog jumping from lilies
to lilies on the pond and
following a regular drumbeat.
So what is left to define
are the various probabilities
of transitions, such as
the transition from i to j,
and the notation
we're going to use
is pij, which by definition
is that transition probability
here.
So given that you are in
state i at time s, what
is the probability that you end
up in state j at time s plus 1.
Notice that these transition
priorities here, pij,
are not function of s.
So irrespective of what the
time s that we're talking about,
these transitions
priorities are the same.
So this is what we mean by a
time-homogeneous Markov chain.
In other words, these are
valid for s equal 0, 1, 2,
and so on and so forth.
So the defining feature
of a Markov chain
is the Markov property.
And the Markov
property essentially
says that the past is not
really important in order
to predict the future, as long
as you know where you are now.
Another way of saying
it is that if you
look at the probability
of going next in state j
given that you
are now in state i
and that I give
you, in addition,
the entire trajectories.
So I tell you that it was in i0
at that time, and so on and so
forth, all the way
up to time s minus 1,
where it was in is minus 1.
So it gives you the
entire trajectory
of the chain up to s,
and now I'm asking you,
what is the probability that
you're going to go to s plus 1?
The Markov property here simply
says that that probability here
is again, pij.
So in other words,
all this information
here is of no use to
compute this probability.
Now, note that these transition
probabilities are really
probabilities, in
the following sense.
Right?
So you are in i and then
at the next time step,
you will definitely
jump with probability 1.
And where you're going
to jump will depend,
but the summation
of all possibilities
have to sum up to 1.
So from j equals 1
to n has to be 1.
So now that we have introduced
the main ingredients,
usually we are very interested
in knowing what a Markov
chain is going to
do in the long run.
We are interested in
finding the probability
that the chain is in a state
j after n transitions, given
that it is now in state i.
Now because of the
time-homogeneous,
this is the same thing as that.
In other words, the current
time could be in any time s,
we just have to add s here.
And again, that is nothing
else than this property.
So we are interested in
calculating rij of n for any n.
For n equals 1, this is
nothing else than rij of 1
is the same as this
transition probabilities
that we have defined.
But for n greater than or
equals to 2, what we are seeing
is the introduction of
a key recursion here.
And this is how you would
be able to calculate
these probabilities.
Now, how did we come
up with this recursion?
Well, it's based on a
classical divide and conquer
and essentially, the use of
the total property theorem.
Essentially, you have
the time step here.
This is the current time s.
You are interested
in what's going
to happen at n plus
s and n steps later.
Here you are in state i.
You are interested
in knowing what
is the probability of being
in state j at that time.
And what you simply do
is you look at the step n
plus s minus 1, just
before the last one.
And then you say, well, let
me do a divide and conquer.
This is k here, and
I'm going to look
at evaluating that probability.
And then once I have
that, I will simply
multiply it by this
transition here.
And what happened
is that this here
is nothing else than this
calculation that we have here.
And that's the same thing.
And here, this is
the probability
of one step transition.
And, of course, we have
conditioned on the fact
that we would be
in a state k here,
but k could be any of
these states, right?
And they are m of
them, and this is
why we saw from k equals 1 to m.
So essentially this is
how this key recursion has
been put together,
and we have used,
of course, the Markov
property in order to do that.
Let's do now a little bit of
warm up in terms of calculation
and apply these concepts.